tomorrow I am in the daa Beach Improv
it's going to be great down in Fort
laale Florida tomorrow Friday and then
shows on Saturday and then the following
week we are in New Haven Connecticut
Thursday Providence Rhode Island Friday
Medford Massachusetts Saturday all those
shows are almost sold out then we have
Phoenix Arizona December uh 2 uh
December 1st and 2nd at Friday Saturday
Phoenix Arizona um back at the um
standup live which is a great menu um
I've been there a couple of times before
but I'm doing my brand new hour going to
do a bunch of got some crowd work got
some new bits you haven't heard so go
check it out and then Salt Lake City and
Denver all those shows are almost sold
out and then we added The Wil turn
theater in Los Angeles and uh show in
San Diego in January Chris DC comedy.com
for tickets I'm really proud of this
hour so come have fun and love your
life don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe heyab
heab heab all right what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of hey babe
um and S is back how you
doing that's s Sal volcano AKA Jessica
kirston on the podcast today you know
her you love her you've seen her
everywhere Jessica Kiron you ready for
this I don't know if you know
I asked Jasmine my girlfriend who is
your favorite comic and she didn't even
know you were coming on today she said
Jessica Kon really she really you're
number one comic that's so I'm going to
eat her out you should I don't so don't
you love yes you do no because I always
get a sore throat oh you okay what do
you think I would do it even if I got a
sore throat she's she's so beautiful
yeah she is um now how are you first of
all you look fantastic thank you I'm
starving thank you I know me too do you
do the fasting you look great no I don't
I can't fast I'm so medicated I'll get
sick I have I'm on so much medication
what's the latest glasses off what is
that I know no I like them you're so
cute you know how much I love you I love
you so much I feel bad cuz you've been
texting me a lot and I haven't been
getting back I've been I've been saying
hey Jess it's you know um you okay you
okay that's what you know when I'm not
getting back to you I'm not okay she
just she just sends me back a thumbs
down I do
not why um well I'm coughing cuz I have
Co but I'm fine I mean Hey listen Co at
this point I want to be around people
that get it now whose side do you want
Israel or Palestine no I'm kidding
Russia Palestine um no uh we we'll edit
that out I'm just joking um I um I I
haven't seen you I haven't seen you in
it feels like months and months and
months now and um and uh but you're one
of those people that every time I see
you it's like I saw you yesterday I know
we love each other very much we really
do I wish I was a woman so you'd [__] me
really I can [__] you anyway no well I
mean thank you so much it took a long
time that's disrespectful to give her a
little bottle of water she said she's
like I just you're loaded why am I
getting this is like for a baby I know
exactly where's my coffee it's not yeah
where where's J you kiding you're what's
not working more anti-Semitism that we
have to deal with you have that you have
to deal with unbelievable no it's Peach
I brought it's pee diet or it's her pee
in a bottle D you would buy me Diet
you're saying I'm
fat no I'll take the diet
[__] thank you Jessica Now suck my dick
but I've been on the road so long you
know I'm always on the road so what is
your when you go on the road we were
just talking about cry right me too I I
it's it's one of those things we have to
do it but because I've been in order to
avoid uh Temptation on the road is I I I
mean I masturbate seriously four to six
times a day to the point where it
affects my relationship because then
when I get home J's like oh you haven't
seen me in 5 days let's have sex and I'm
like I don't have any fluids left and
she's like what [__] is it and I'm like
I liter I've been jerking off the Sports
Center in the in the in the holiday list
yes do you do what is it about that when
you get on the road you just want to you
just want to jerk off a little bit well
I I'm I'm not saying this to be funny I
I masturbate to take depression naps so
I yeah cuz I I really sometimes I can't
nap and I need to nap during the day cuz
I don't leave the the hotel room right
so if I rub one out I'm able to nap
right that's really the truth seriously
it's the only thing that puts me to
sleep as well yeah you know I'm curious
what you watch at this point well okay
so what I watch at this I'm being dead
serious I believe you what I watch at
this point is for me Now porn it's too
excessive porn is actually disgusting to
me now where I'm like this is too much
like it's not turn it's it's barbaric at
this point but I've watched so much of
it so I think so what I watched um I was
just in um Columbus Ohio two days ago
and I actually masturbated to the
trailer for the new movie
Napoleon but but I don't know what it is
about that because I think it just what
it does is when I watch something that's
not sexual at all it distracts my mind
enough where I think I'm just kind of
like at peace and I either off to like
memories that I've had sexual memories
or or you know I I'm because if the
point it's it's too hypersexual for me
is it bad that I masturbate to war
footage no you sure really as long as
it's America's winning the war you can't
you can't you can't masturbate to enemy
footage no it's never enemy footage it's
all us doing horrible things to other
people do you you feel like you're on
like a NeverEnding Comedy Tour and you
want it to end but you know it can't end
that's what my tour is called the
never-ending tour right that's yeah yeah
I can't I can't stop I mean honestly
it's like saving my life right now I
mean I just I when I'm home for too long
it's really not good but do you think
you can like perpetually just be on the
road no I mean I have to I'm taking a
break now for a couple of weeks but I I
I'm you're I know you'll take like a
month or two off like I haven't done
that in I don't think I've ever done
that you haven't so in all your 20 plus
years of Comedy you have never taken one
month off no it's every how many
weekends a year roughly would you say
you're actually on the road performing
like away from your
family if you have to guess I mean
lately it's been a lot because now I'm
like selling out theaters and stuff you
know or four weekends a month every
month no no no no no no now it's like
three out of four but you know it hasn't
been this much you know in the past I
mean this that's this year right right
but like next year it's not going to be
this much but it's just I'm riding the
wave right now we got to ride the wave
but I think I think I think you know we
talk about this sometimes where like
oversaturation too sometimes I feel like
I get I oversaturate myself because we
have so many hours of podcast there's so
much content I don't do that see you do
a podcast also so I'm not doing a
podcast now so it's less
and I have like I have the next two
weeks off which I'm excited about so um
but and and December's light which is
good so I me I I I do have some time off
coming up but I I've also enjoyed it
because I have all these fans coming to
like sold out shows and I I didn't
always have that so it's very exciting
for me um are your fans um mostly
lesbians no no my manager says I'm like
the Grateful Dead for the mentally ill
yes yeah that's merch yeah it is the
Grateful de for the mental I would buy
that shirt yeah my shirts and hats say
dead inside and um and I talk to myself
it's smart yeah I mean really most of my
my fans are all different kind a lot of
gay men now a lot which is incredible um
yeah I mean it's all different kinds of
people every club and theater says that
they're like you have such like every
kind of person comes to your shows it's
like a it's like a people um yeah do you
have for the little people how do you
what do you when I say hi they come up
to my vagina it's amazing well to get
them onto the stage do they have like a
slingshot type thing how do you get them
up there of course yeah they just and
they vagina just goes right to my face
it's amazing the vagina speaking of
vaginas the vagina alarm clock um is a
uh you can put this in your vagina and
what does it do um pimp uh you can hit
the snooze button it just vibrates
inside you until you wake up what do you
think of that that is hysterical are you
into that I love it I wish it would just
blow up and kill me and my vagina
right this podcast episode sponsored by
betterhelp we love the folks at better
help right now this time of year can be
a lot and it's natural to feel some
sadness or anxiety about it therapy can
be a bright spot amid all of the stress
and change something to look forward to
make you feel grounded and to give you
the tools to manage everything going on
whether or not you've been in therapy
personally or not I'm telling you
therapy is awesome it's helped me a lot
it's helped a lot of people I know and
better help is is great because you
don't actually have to go to the office
you do it all online and they match you
up with the license therapist that fits
your needs and it's a beautiful thing if
you're starting if you're thinking of if
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
done online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule all you do is fill out the
brief questionnaire to get match with
the licensed therapist and you switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge go to betterhelp that's
hp.com to get 10% % off your first month
that's
betterhelp.com 10% off your first month
beam dream powder first of all if you
want to get a good night's sleep beam
dream powder is for you the cocoa flavor
is banging did you know that poor sleep
can cause weight gain mood issues poor
mental health and lower productivity so
that's why you're getting fat you're a
moody little [__] and you just can't
focus it's cuz you're not getting enough
sleep it's happened to me sleep is the
foundation
of mental and physical health you need
it and let me tell you something beam
dream remember s would always talk about
beam dream powder that's actually why
he's not here right now is he's asleep
he's we've been calling him Rumple still
skin ever since he's drinking this beam
dream powder the guy just sleeps all day
and he loves it he loves life and he's a
beautiful beautiful man a recal CL a
recent clinical study revealed dream
help 93% of users wake up feeling more
refreshed and 93% reported that dream
helped them get a more restful night's
sleep today my listeners are going to
get a special discount on beams dream
powder their best-selling healthy hot
cocoa for sleep this one is so good with
no added sugar now it's available in
delial in delicious seasonal flavors
like cinnamon cocoa sea salt caramel and
white chocolate peppermint better sleep
has never tasted better if you want to
buy beam's bestselling dream powder take
advantage of their biggest sale of the
year and get up to 50% off off for a
limited time when you go to shop
beam.com bab the discount is auto
applied at checkout no code necessary
that's shop
beam.com heyab up to 50% off go beam it
door Dash is the only place I use for
delivery I love door Dash you can order
anything when I'm when I want food late
at night early in the day the middle of
day door Dash baby door Dash first of
all all I'm going to tell you that
you're going to get a you're going to
get a sick offer you get if all you have
to do if you go to Door dash.com get
that go into the app store get the door
Dash app all you have to do is use the
code hey babe holiday that's H YB a b h
o l i d a y hey babe holiday get 50% off
up to a $10 value when you spend $15 or
more at convenience grocery or select
retail stores on door Dash terms of of
course door Dash use the code hey babe
holiday 50% off up to $10 value when you
spend $15 or more at convenience grocery
or select retail stores on door Dash
order now and get the gift list the
grocery list and other holiday
essentials from door Dash as a dash pass
member this is what I like about door
Dash you become a dash pass member you
can enjoy exclusive offers and Peaks all
season long on stocking stuffers Decor
groceries meals and more you'll also get
a 0 delivery fee and reduce service fees
on eligible orders too all right guys so
right now order now and get the holiday
help you need from door Dash use code
hey babe holiday to get 50% off up to a
$10 value when you spend $15 or more at
convenience grocery or select retail
stores on door Dash terms apply shop
door Dash to get everything you need for
the holiday season they um um my uh
daughter um she said that one of they
had a fire drill at their school you
know we've all had the fire drill
where they take you outside or whatever
and she said one of the kids ran away in
the fire drill just like just walked
away and left and then just like went
and rang their parents' Bell at like
11:00 a.m. and was like I I don't want
to be in school anymore and they were
like what the hell God how old I don't
know like third grade fourth grade well
I don't know if it was her class but I
was like that's interesting kids I mean
you know I feel like we are like when I
talk can you tell that story again cuz
it was really interesting and I feel
like people want to hear it again what
the my about the kid walking away
there's a fire drill I'm joking at my oh
oh yeah I know you never ditch school
you guys no I didn't go to school in
high school I'm shocked that I graduated
from high school right because I was
high all the time right and I just cut
school and like no one my parents didn't
even know where I they weren't around so
like I just never went to school I yeah
I'm serious I was a total burnout yeah
but but but I feel like you know Co it
co but I but but a lot of people now say
the American education system they they
hate it anyway they think it doesn't do
any good for us it's a me can I just
tell you everything's a mess I'm kind
I'm really having a hard time I mean we
don't have to get into everything but
like I'm I don't have a lot of Hope
because of World stuff everything yeah
well I mean cuz you can say just turn
off the news but now you're starting to
see it in public now you're starting to
see it in your person I meant to say
starting to see like like types of crazy
[__] but that's why I um that's why I
kind of I I go around and I you know um
I kiss people on the lips that's what I
do to just desensitize I'll go up to you
know like today there was a uh the the
um the the newspaper guy uh Rafiki I
walked up to him what's his name Rafiki
oh I love that name yes and I walked up
to him and he asked me what I wanted the
New York Post of Daily News and I just
started make I just kissed him on the
lips was he a good kisser yeah he was
good he doesn't have teeth so it was
like Kiss it was like kissing a guppy
fish you should have him Rim you I do
yeah
again you know I I told you this i' i' I
very infrequently have gotten my ass
eaten and the couple times I've done it
makes me come really quick which has
made uh Jazz think I'm
gay I don't think that means you're gay
because that's a very sensitive area I
know
[Music]
allegedly oh oh zoom in on her
[Applause]
cough I don't I just have had a cough
but I'm not I'm not sick I wouldn't care
at this point it's not it's it's from
being in the oven I'm a
Jew I feel like you'd taste good though
you'd be like a cinnam like a like a
cinnamon swirl that's his hysterical
what you just said cuz I am like a bear
like a honey bear yeah you are yeah
you're like I'm very clean I really I am
you are you are no you really are I'm
serious I'm like I smell good you you
you know yeah but you're yeah I do I
take good care of myself I just shaved
today how come women can't wear
yamakas the hell did that just come from
they can there's a lot of like very
liberal like Brooklyn Jewish women that
wear yamakas now right I might wear one
cuz I have a ball spot from
stress
I'm not relig I mean like I'm proud to
be Jewish but I'm not relig I tell you
this because I I you know the very
religious Jews don't accept me because I
eat box isn't isn't it funny how you're
at and this happens to a lot of people
how you're at like the most success
you've had in your career but then you
also feel like the most like shattered
as like a person but you've had this is
like the success that you're having if I
told you Jess 15 years ago when we first
met 12 years ago Jess this is what
you're going to have sold out theater
tour whatever you'd be like I would be
so happy
and then and then but you're coming in
here in a in a black turtleneck you feel
like that a black turtleneck I know I'm
sitting shiv my own life do do you feel
like that yeah but what I I feel like
you're happy well I think I was telling
when I was telling Colin Quinn we had
him on the show last week when I was
telling him I think what's happened with
me and my life and my relationship is a
lot of my friends are starting to get
divorced now but Jazz and I are like the
strongest we've ever been because we
went the opposite we didn't stay
together and and then get married and
then bring a child and we had we
literally were like Z to 100 right away
and then it's taken 10 years but now
we're like oh all the problems that our
friends are having I'm like we I did
that I did that in 2015 I had that
problem I had that problem five years
ago like I that's it's now we're just
like kind of like tolerant of it all so
I would say I'm definitely happier um
but I do think what's happening I think
with me with with my career personally
is I'm starting to be like as I'm going
through this I'm like do I I don't even
know if I want to like I never cared
about being like the best comic of all
time I'm like I don't know if I
necessarily need this to be my whole
life like I I you know I I don't know I
don't know what else I really want to do
but I'm starting to be like H you know
sometimes it doesn't feel fulfilled
because it's become like a job it's
become less about the passion more like
a job so you want to go find the passion
again but it it takes a lot of balls to
walk away and go find the passion again
you know what I mean yeah well I I
always knew that getting famous or
filling up a theater or having people
stand up and clap would not fill the
hole right well you were around famous
people before you had any success at all
since I'm a teenager right so you see
what that does to people right it
doesn't it I knew it wouldn't make me
happy you know and I think that if
anything sometimes it can make you more
sad because it's like you see you know
I'm performing for a thousand people
every night and they're standing up and
screaming and then when they meet me
they're like oh my God Jessica I can't
believe I'm really meeting you I was
and I'm like oh my God I'm so depressed
I'm like so anxious lately I'm going
through so much in my life and this is
even sadder like this is even more
upsetting well you know I the happiest
people I'm realizing now are Anonymous
like my friends my friends who have
don't have a career like they could
literally tweet whatever they wanted and
nobody would care are Far and Away the
happiest people I know they don't have a
High Cost of Living nobody cares about
what they say at all nobody could give a
[__] they have their lives they have
their small circles and they they're
home every weekend they never miss
anything and they're like yeah I don't
need to be a you know like they don't
need to have all this uh Power and I
think I think that a lot of people think
that when you get that from the audience
or from fans that that's makes you happy
and for me I I I want that from a person
right or you know relationship or from
the people in my life like that's what
what what I needed from not from right
you know all these fans and whatever
like it's it's um it's so interesting I
think people think you're immediately
happy if you have all that attention and
you're famous or you now I think Fame
now has become a thing like I don't even
think kids necessarily going to strive
to be a celebrity anymore I think like
the the curtain's been pulled back about
like how miserable like life can be for
people who are like extremely famous
like you don't you don't want that
today's society you don't want that you
can't get away with anything you know
yeah I mean what's your goal now is it
still like to have is it what's your
goal you sound you didn't say the L you
sounded like a Korean what's your goal
what's your goal now like Bobby Lee that
was Bobby what's your goal um um my goal
is to I'd like to have a uh uh like a a
TV show in New York based in New York
where I can go every day my life as I go
to like I don't h i do stand up if I
want to and it's there but I don't have
to I don't have like I just want to be I
want to just be home like I don't I want
to be home for like a year and I don't I
don't have to go anywhere I'm just like
in my neighborhood at all times and if I
want to take a little trip I can I don't
want to have to be like forced to go
away I know it's the standup gets tough
like when you're constantly doing these
shows and promoting and on the road it's
a lot when you especially when you have
a family well that's another thing I
realized too is like the more you put on
your plate then the more shows you had
the more you have to promote it's all
energy so you have to just be careful
you know when you have multiple kids too
like we have multiple children when you
have one kid or no kids it's different
when you have multiple kids it's like I
I have like almost zero energy as soon
as I wake up I mean like you know you
know how it is we I've been up today I
went to the a concert last night we took
my daughter to see pink and oh how was
it she's [__] amazing she was flying
over pink flew right over us I went like
this I'm like that I was like [__] in
myou mouth you're like yeah and it was
amazing um my daughter loved it uh Jazz
love we we had so much fun um and then
uh and then you know we um we we we we
got home you know 12 1:00 and then you
know you wake up at 5:15 and then you're
like and then and then I'm like what do
I have to do now and I have to go talk
for two hours what do I what do you want
me to talk about I'm hung over I what am
I going to say I can I just talk tonight
on stage and do stand up or something
like that yeah you're like no no you got
to do a Hello fresh yeah it's it you
better the ads your ad go the ads money
you got to do that and it starts to
become like am I in a [__] a job a
job I'm like I I I started comedy to not
be in a day to not have a day job but
now you have a day job yeah so it's but
it's it's what it's what it is it's it's
how you perceive everything that's all
it really is and I always try to stay
grateful and realize things could be a
lot worse of course a lot worse of like
yeah what like how could it be worse
what you could be doing everything
you're doing but you could have no hands
or feet well these are fake you have
fake feet yeah and hands yeah could you
imagine you had no hands and feet but
you still had to go around and do your
job how would you walk I don't know I
mean people there there's Pro prothetic
how do you say it proe prothetic yeah
that's how they say in Sp pathetic
pae if I talk like that would you be
friends with me yeah no you wouldn't I
would somehow when you talk like that
you sound
less
really would you if I was really hot and
I talk like that would you sleep with me
I mean you
know yes I would that's a dumb question
CU I know you would I would no but I
don't but but lately I've had no sex
drive lately I'm looking for someone
else to have sex with my wife really
yeah I wouldn't care at this point I
don't even think she would care I think
half the time we're having sex she
thinks it's somebody
[Laughter]
else you have good
wrists how did you even notice that I
looking at your wrists you do have nice
wrists I was a tennis player for many
now I don't do anything but stand up and
cry but I really was I was stand up
adding stand up and cry is what makes
that brilliant and I think a lot of
people don't realize that yeah stand up
and cry is just a funny thing to add
that makes no sense but also perfect
sense that's actually a good name for my
new my Netflix special I'm filming stand
up and cry yeah stand up and cry when
does it come out I haven't filmed it yet
but it'll come out next year at some
point where you going to film it where
where do you think I I'm deciding you
know I was going to do it in Jersey
where I grew up but I don't I don't love
the options where so either in New York
but I also love Chicago how great of a
city is Chicago I love Chicago so I'm
just trying to decide I don't know right
pimp where should she shoot
it um I like Chicago or Jersey Red Bank
is cool decent room Paramount Long
Island is awesome I love the Paramount I
I I just did show a show there I loved
it that's a great room and you also have
a special out on YouTube yes yes that
and who shot it who shot it homeless
pimp and then and then and then I the
Steve Steve who was came on the road
with me Chone was doing the edits on the
clips though cuz he kept saying I have
to put in edits for Jessica no I don't
know who that is I don't know was he I
thought he was doing isn't there a guy
named Steve no he does um he does some
of my t he does my Tik Tok Tik Tok okay
that's what it is I thought it had
something to do have a whole
team we got a team I would I would love
to hear more um of your burnout stories
from high school I knew you were going
to ask about that I was a big burnout in
high school I was a pod you know I
started doing drugs at this is opposite
from you I started drinking and doing
drugs like 1213 and I went right into it
what drugs what where' you go you alcoh
pot pot never like any snorting or
heroin of course not heroin not heroin
but oh yeah yeah no I'm a drug ad you
know I'm in recovery for years now but I
was um and I've been in and out many
times but I'm sober now for years thank
God you think you can relapse it's
always possible I could relapse the
second I walk out of this I almost just
said office um I'm shocked I am shocked
didn't relapse in the past 3 months I'm
seeing I'm saying that honestly and I'm
shocked I didn't been going through hell
in my life and I came this close to
relapsing and I'm so grateful I didn't
because you haven't though that must
make you feel powerful it does I'm I'm
really grateful because I would have had
to count days over I could have not come
back I could have ended up dead in jail
or an institution that's what we say
what's the itch alcohol um no I I'm not
as much bread bread is yeah I [__] my
face with bread I haven't had bread in 3
years no I know that's why I haven't had
a piece of bread a bite it's wild how
you can what's always been amazing to me
about you Jessica is how when you talk
about like your drugs about how you had
a point in your life where you would
just cave to drugs and alcohol like you
say but now you are like the strongest
one of the most strongest minded people
I know that you haven't had bread in
three years so it's interesting how like
a person can be both things how you
could cave so easy but then be literally
Al one of the strongest minded people
that I've ever met thank you I mean
addiction is a disease of the mind and
once you realize that you're powerless
over something it's very freeing you
know right and I can't do it alone so
like you know I I that's what you do
with the Nation of
[Laughter]
Islam I love you dress like yeah I am
you know like you're in the nation of is
I'm miserable anyway so but I started
with pot and alcohol and alcohol was not
I mean I never went out I would never
went out and had one drink I'd be like
what point of this so I would drink
until I was sick or could but I I don't
love alcohol I'm very blessed so I
haven't had a drink in 23 years but
drugs are my thing so I can't have one
hit a pot I can't have one line of coke
I mean most people can't have one line
of coke but I can't take one pill like I
mean it's there's no point I I'm a
vacuum I'm a garbage can I want to get
up I want to be obliv I want to be out
Knock myself out not feel and I can't
stop go hard or go home you go all the
way in yeah I can't it's I have a
disease like I can't um it's just I
can't people are like can why can't you
just have a little pot I'm like no I
can't the minute I have it's in my body
I will keep using in high school would
you get in trouble like is there a crazy
no I wasn't there I wasn't like my
parents weren't around a lot so I kind
of just did what I wanted to do and then
I just my friends and I partied a lot I
did a ton of X in college a ton a ton it
was Heavy it was Heavy [__] was not like
it is now it was like you could have
easily died um you would be dead today
actually cuz there' be a high chance of
fentanyl would be in oh sure I would
have easily could have done fentanyl
yeah I was um yeah I mean I did a lot of
ecstasy in in high school I did shrooms
a lot I did some cocaine in high school
before they were cool before they were
dipped in chocolate you did old
schoolrooms old school yes smell like
[__] tastes like [__] shrooms yeah um
and then when I graduated uh College I I
did more coke and stuff and I put myself
in rehab I sent myself away to rehab
what's amazing about you is You' did all
those drugs did all that coke but that
was at a point in your life where your
weight was the heaviest and now you've
look like a completely different person
you've lost all the weight and you don't
do any drugs cuz normally it's it's the
opposite people when they're using are
thin and then when they go into rehab
they need something to do with their
hands and they gain weight but you're
opposite yeah I mean I think because I
started looking at food like it's an
addiction and that helped me a lot of
people don't they don't understand like
I don't eat anything I'm addicted to so
like brown rice I can have a little so
I'll eat it but I know this might sound
weird to some people but white rice I'll
binge on right because white is better
than brown yeah is what you're saying it
is I'm I'm this is true for me so like I
don't eat sugar because I can't stop
right but like like I I eat protein I'm
not going to overeat you know just there
c chicken yeah there's exactly there's
things I'm not going to overeat so I can
eat as much as I want of them but
there's things that I just don't like I
don't eat pasta I can't have a little
bit of pasta I can't I know that so I
don't eat it so you just avoid it so
what's like your big Indulgence
indulgent food what's the riskiest
craziest you go like this is a cheat
bite or meal well sometimes I'll have a
bite of a dessert or you know one bite
yeah because I I but you see how
powerful that is though how like most of
us can't do that I know but you know
what it's like life or death to me and I
have kids and I'm on the road a lot I
can't function if I do I'll lose
everything right but you only got to
that by almost dying but I also do it
with support see I can't do it alone
like the minute I stop going to support
groups
the minute I stop going to support
groups and stop reaching out to people
and stop you know doing what I need to
do I relapse or I start eating again
like I I've tried doing it alone and it
doesn't work it just doesn't have you
ever tried just to get a taste of it and
this is a serious question because I've
heard adex do this have you ever tried
like you know like you can't have the
cheesecake but you've like shoved it in
your
ass I have I have a Kaiser role in my
[__] right now you do I have a kaiser
roll in my [__] Dr Squatch the best
soap I've ever had in my life they just
sent five bars of soap to my apartment
and you could smell it in the Box even
the postman was like yo you got a box
that smells good and it was bars of soap
I open it right there I gave my Postman
a bar of soap and he's the cleanest
Postman in the neighborhood Dr Squatch
is different and I like it it's
different than the H than the
traditional soaps out there you got high
performance natural products B core
certified no harm full ingredients have
you looking good smelling good and
feeling your best and the sensory
experience in the shower and on your
skin is amazing it's true I am in that
shower way too long cuz I'm doing things
you're not supposed to do with that dror
Squatch soap bar but I love it you buy
three soaps and get three soaps for free
$28 in savings like getting each bar for
$4 offer only valid for new customers
they got free
shipping one of Dr squatch's founding
missions is to encourage men to pay
attention to the ingredients they use on
their body okay it is the perfect
holiday gift gift stocking stuffer or
just a treat for yourself I genuinely
love taking showers now I used to kind
of take one one shower a week maybe two
but now I'm showering twice a day every
day because I got the doctor Squatch
soap and I like the way it feels on my
body they got cool fresh aloe which they
sent me that's the one I use pinear soap
which you think oh it's pinear I'm
telling you you're going to love
cleaning yourself with pinear Bay Rum
soap fresh fall soap wood barrel Bourbon
soap Birchwood Breeze soap it's amazing
it is awesome okay and by the way all
those soaps I I read out those are um
included in the buy three get three off
so right now Dr Squatch is offering our
listeners a huge savings okay all new
customers will get three free bars of
soap plus free shipping with any
purchase of three bars all you have to
do listen to me I'm telling you this is
like the greatest holiday gift stocking
stuffer or for your husband or you know
whatever this is I love these soaps
drsquatch.com that's d r SQ
ach.com
to receive this buy three get three
offer that's Dr SQ ach.com heyab to buy
three soaps and get three free it is
time to get the daily routine Essentials
you'll need to start feeling good and
smelling like a man today let me tell
you about the absolute best toothbrush
I've ever had in my life quip baby look
at this hit that
button and we're brushing folks quip
toothbrush I use it every day it's great
to travel because it has like this like
plastic case that goes over it that's
awesome keeps my uh toothbrush germ free
I love the vibration the little Sonic
vibration on my teeth it's amazing
you're going to want to use it on other
parts of your body but do not do that
this is only a toothbrush for your teeth
and it is awesome let me tell you
about quip good health starts with good
habits and quip makes it Easy by
delivering all the O care Essentials you
need to Care Free mouth they also have
these amazing mints this tooth floss
seriously quip is and I love the
toothpaste it's so minty fresh and I
just feel like my teeth are cleaner
wouldn't you say my teeth are looking
better quip baby quip is doing from now
on my friends are going to start calling
me Colin quip I love quip so much it is
lightweight and Sleek design no wires no
bulky charges to weigh you down
multi-use travel cover that doubles as a
mirror amount for Less clutter and it is
it really does it looks awesome skip the
batteries and snap into healthy habits
with the new rechargeable electric
toothbrush all the features of the
original quip plus one magnetic charge
Powers up to three months of brushing I
never have to I'm I'm telling you I
barely charge this thing I really do
like stand by this product this is the
best toothbrush I've ever
had the water flosser it hits all the
right spots with gentle or deep clean
pressure at the touch of a button extra
wide lid that fits right under the
faucet and fills up in seconds $7
replacement floss uh uh floss tips Shi
to you every three months to keep things
flowing smoothly and prevent mineral
deposits from building up every time you
pop our new mints you'll be caring for
your mouth inside and out bold mint
flavors keep your breath confidently
fresh and you'll get a boost of vitamin
D here look I'll show you I'll show you
the mints right here look these are the
mints right here look at these
unbelievable these quip mints and
they're just look they pop right open
like a Pez dispenser it's fun and the
mints are so fresh I love them and you
guys are going to get a great discount
all you do is you got to go to
getquip.com heyab right now and you will
get 20% off any electric toothbrush mint
and gum dispenser or water flosser
that's
getquip.com
bab right now that's 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flaer at G
quip.com
that is
gq.com
quip the good habits
company
yey um do
you what
um um so so yeah because because that's
why you know your your mind when I talk
every time I talked to him like oh wow
Jess is just like she can when because
I've known you haven't eaten bread in
now it's three years I remember it was
two years just a year ago and and I
remember being like Oh my God I I
couldn't go more than a week without
eating bread but you could just you have
the power over it and then there was a
point I was eating just gluten-free
bread I mean it's hilar that's how much
of a liar and how crazy I am where I'm
like I'm just going to eat gluten-free
bread I'm not even glutenfree and it's
all so high and fat it's not okay it's
the same [__] exactly but I was eating
like six pieces a day right so you're
eating full bread it's not okay like
it's it's not healthy no yeah and I'm so
that's how much of a liar I can be like
I'm not kidding I would binge on toasted
like corn chips because I was like it's
corn right so I can eat a bag of corn
corn it's like a vegetable a serving a
vegetable like I'm out in my mind right
yeah I mean but and well and not
drinking is good too I mean like
yesterday I you know all I did was like
I'm not going to eat anything at the
Pink concert I'm just going to drink and
I had like three or four vodka sodas and
it's like you should have just eaten a
cheeseburger that would have been better
for you you're just just because you're
you know not drinking um but yeah I mean
I don't know and that didn't make you
want to eat like whenever I drank I
wanted to eat I did I really really
really wanted to eat but Jasmine was
like don't eat like you know see you
have that support that's good yeah but
yeah it's not easy but I'm also older
now and I've relapsed and
um a bunch of times and it's also
humiliating and it's good it's good to
to talk about it and be honest but see I
isolate like we're not joking like
you've texted me like three times I'm an
isolator it's not good right like that's
part of the program and part of being
sober is to like not isolate and I have
a big thing with that it's not healthy
to isolate like to not reach out to not
get back to people to kind of handle it
on your own and I have been going
through a lot recently and I need to
reach out more to people this is great
episode of hey
babe hey babe is always like when me and
Sal's always like we're happy talking
and then the last two episodes cuz he
hasn't been here I've just been like hey
let me talk about how miserable I am is
this not good that it's so serious F
this is fine the fan you know how it is
podcast fans because one of us isn't
here they're going to hate the episode
regardless there's no but you will have
a I remember the last time I did it
people were like where's s when's s
coming back well that that's that's
what'll happen so it doesn't matter
you'll just have people that are like
you know everybody by the way I'm
getting sick and tired of everybody
saying that they're on the Spectrum
you're not okay either put on a helmet
and bite me or you're not autistic just
shut up I'm really getting just
everybody thinks now that they're like a
victim everyone's like oh I'm on the
Spectrum I can't shut up I want if we're
not get if I'm not getting a tetanus
shot every time we hang out cuz you bit
my ankles like like an autistic kid
would then stop telling me that you're
on the Spectrum I've just had enough of
people to be going to watch this and say
that I'm on the Spectrum no just podcast
fans in general will are very much like
if the thing is if the if like an
autistic if it's not exactly like it is
birth control if it's not exactly like
it is every time like I can't listen I
I'll listen one well that's ridiculous
that's how people are first of all this
is the thing we have a life sometimes
you have to record and someone has to do
something you have to you got to
sometimes you have to plus s is I love S
I miss him
oh he's he is kindest most I I I love
him best cabs in the business c yeah and
you're adorable oh God I can't take it I
want to like squeeze you yeah you know
how much I love you oh [__] I already
did is I wish I wasn't in a yellow are
you doing all stuff all day today cuz
it's pretty early it's like noon are you
doing are you have to be in the city all
day now no no no no no I'm you just came
in for this I came in for this and then
I have stuff to do and then I have the
kids I have the kids in the afternoon
afterno and tonight you know I have my
children but what do you nap no only
when I'm on the road not when I'm home
cuz when you're home you can't nap no I
have my children right but on the road I
try to I try to before my shows cuz it's
I get anxious right um this morning my
2-year-old [__] on the floor are you
kidding cuz she's potty training so we
kind of we don't mind but we're like as
long as it's not in your diaper that's
Jazz's rule yes she Violet um my
daughter my uh sorry my older daughter
when she was two she [__] in one of my
duffel bags I swear going on the road
and I didn't know and I put my clothes
in it was in there it was in one of the
side pockets and I just had like socks
and underwear in the side pocket and
when I got to I think I was in Baltimore
I was doing mooes in Tonia Maryland I
took it out and I was like why do my
sock smell like [__] and then cuz she
had a she had a little turd in in the
little pocket cute right you're such a
good daddy do you um yeah I mean I know
our kids are like the same age too yeah
roughly the same age is she is is uh is
your little ones are they partty
training training they're done yeah
they're they're four and a half now oh
right yeah I have twin four and a half
year olds oh yeah so they should thank
God they're all pretty they all right
pretty pretty girls oh God just makes
life so much easier cuz what do you do
if you know you have an ugly kid cuz
there are some parents who know they
don't you think so no they think that
they think that there's Beauty to them
to them I think that there are some
parents that say you know what this
child will always be beautiful to me and
lovely to me but they know that
society's be like this is not a pretty
kid I think I think I think that there's
parents that know and then you just deal
with it I don't uh our kids are going to
be ugly to someone even though even
though we have beautiful children
somebody's going to be like that's an
ugly kid or that's an ugly person I'll
kill them I know but I'm just saying
it's the truth I'm scared if I'm around
and I'm not saying I'm serious if I'm
around and someone's mean to my child
I'm afraid at what I would do I'm like
insane with that like I will kill
someone right I'm not kidding I it's not
good yeah we had to tell I to tell
Jasmine she can't come my daughter's in
gymnastics and it's like rushing
gymnastics and they are serious like
they even even like one of the parents
the very first day was like come on
sweetie like just cheering her daughter
and she's like do you want to be coach
do you want to be coach because we need
coach if you're a parent here you shut
mouth like and they were like yelling
and then and then my daughter you know
they were like this is this what you
call stretching your body is not it's
made of wood you should do that on stage
you need to do this on stage it's true
cuz your have you done that no do it and
then Jazz have he won't do it but I'm
telling you this is really funny be
because you should you should do it then
you're on the side doing like push-ups
and yeah because it's true I mean and I
had to ask get on the train she goes his
body's made of wood and Jazz and Jazz
was like yo she was like she was like
off to side she's like this [__] better
not be talking about my daughter I'm
like she is and then the Russian she
said that this is not American
Gymnastics school this is Russian
gymnastics school and then so and then
and the J's like we need to take her out
we need to take her out of gymnastics
I'm like no no this is what she needs
she needs [__] discipline she needs
to get Russian discipline I want rline
rline I want to wrestle a bear I'm so
hungry me too I'm starving do you have
an omelet station here or something I
hope I'm so like legitimately what would
you eat right now if you could eat any
like breakfast let's say breakfast it's
being dead serious I'm serious tell me
exactly what you'd want two a tea two a
tea yes I I want right now is um a bacon
egg and cheese with avocado and Chipotle
mayo on a pretzel roll oh my
God you ready for this a fresh a fresh
hot chocolate chip muffin toasted with
butter oh my God this is amazing that's
amazing IC coffee with pumpkin
cream and then and then I also would
want to get what do you want for dessert
no well I was going to say I also I want
to get chocolate chip chocolate chip
banana peanut butter pancakes for the
table but I holy [__] but I'll eat 75%
of them and then I want to leave that
pancake sounds unbelievable and then I
want to leave I want to go for like a
little walk to like digest and like wait
until like the the nausea and heartburn
and like feeling of Li hairness go away
I swear to God and then I want a um a
pepperoni Sicilian with the old school
pepperoni on it like a deep dish
pepperoni like the real crunchy crust I
want that with a uh Diet Coke and
mozzarella sticks you and I have very
similar taste I didn't know you like
Diet Coke the difference is I'll do it
the difference is is like you you don't
think you would do if I the difference
is I will do it you won't do it you have
the you have the the kind of intestinal
fortitude to be like I'm not going to I
want to do that but I'm not going to do
it yeah I I like everything you said I'm
not into the pumpkin thing but I like
literally every other thing you said the
pump the the banana with the peanut
butter and the oh my God and the
chocolate chip muffin
The only positive thing that say the
chocolate chip muffin with butter I
would put but I would have the butter
showing like it wouldn't all melt I put
pounds of butter on yeah no I love that
I I I I I I try to wait I was doing for
a while only sweets on Saturdays but it
got I remember I lost control and now I
just try to do like sweets every other
day cuz I can't live my life like that
the only thing that has been is Saving
Grace I've been working more on
flexibility in the gym as opposed to
just lifting weights I mean trying to
get more flexible and active that way so
when I really am craving a pepperoni
pizza I don't do it instead I just lick
my
nipples and they're salty and they're
Sal yeah yeah I have the saltiest
sweatiest nipples and I you know what's
crazy is is is I don't ever smell isn't
that like what like you don't get boo no
I I don't I don't hardly ever I I can't
even remember the last time I had bo
yeah like nobody even like even like
when I'm like work out or whatever like
I don't ripping farts not you know like
have just like a crusty ass I just never
smell what is that I I think it's what
you eat and how you take care of
yourself I don't but I don't wash my ass
like how your ass never smells cuz I ask
Jazz I'm like tell me if I smell and
she's like I you know like at times like
you know like yeah maybe it doesn't
smell as good as other times but like I
never sometimes my breath smells I think
here I think it's from your diet I'm
serious it is from your diet tell the TR
you guys ever smelled my breath you
always smell good you do what is it cuz
it's from your diet isn't itet it is
it's all your diet so then what's a
smelly what's a smelly person's diet
what do they I think [__] like they eat
[__] no I don't mean literal [__] I
think they don't eat healthy no some
healthy people some people have really
healthy diets they smell it depends what
true some people who eat really healthy
have horrific Bo and bad breath is
caused by odor producing bacteria that
grow in in your mouth when you don't
brush and floss regularly bacteria
accumulate on the bits of food left in
your mouth and between your teeth the
sulfur compounds released by these
bacteria make your breath smell but I
think also there's types of food pimp
pimpy do what types of food make a makes
a person smell like not your breath but
like your body like your ass it says
hormones oh sour CRA oh yeah hormones oh
okay so some people just they're born
smelly it's true there some times you
you'll meet fans and I'll be like that
person smells and they're hot too right
you ever meet a hot person that smells
it's so jarring to meet like a beautiful
woman and they smell and you're like
what I I'll never forget I was I was
hosting a fencing competition and this
fencer was gorgeous like Beyond gorgeous
and then she came to the Afterparty and
you're thinking like oh okay like you
know she just fenced maybe that's why
she smells and then I saw her and I was
like okay I'll just let it pass smell
but then I saw her again like a week
later and she smells even worse and I
met her without fencing first yes I met
her like a coffee and I said to her I
was like did you just fence she was like
no I just came from my apartment and I
was like oh this girl just just rolling
[__] it's weird it's weird yeah I I
[__] her with a hazmat
suit no we didn't have
sex um what sign are you Scorpio my
birthday's next week what yeah amazing
what sign are you I am a Virgo
oh organ are you very
organized I would say no that's
interesting no therez a lot of scorp I
know I didn't think you were I'm like no
I'm I can be what I do I don't it's
maybe it's not organized but it's like I
like cleaning out the
fridge I get that when I come home like
what I'll do lately is I'll leave on a
Thursday or Friday morning and I'll see
something like in the fridge that's like
you know maybe like leftover pasta or
something that's about to expire and
then I'll and then I'll I'll I'll think
about it all week I'll be like I bet
she's not going to throw it out I bet
she's not going to throw it out and then
I'll get home Sunday like I got home
Sunday the first time before I push my
kids out of the way open the fridge and
I'm like who why didn't you throw that
out to the point where she's like if if
it makes you feel powerful and like a
man to clean out the fridge then clean
out the fridge okay and I don't know why
I'm obsessed with that I get so angry
when she doesn't clean out the fridge I
understand I mean there's certain things
that like bother us or make up us obsess
she's like oh I'm taking care of the
children while you're living your dream
while you know because that's the truth
it's you know they we are going out
living our dream and you know you have
need someone to be home and take care of
the kids and then we're getting to live
our dream and do that so but also I'm
like I understand that but clean please
the clean out the fridge yeah but yeah
clean [__] yes you're a
woman um a biological woman I think that
we're going to I think that we're going
to Move podcast Studios and we're not
going to do it here anymore why because
I think the lease is ending but I think
I think it's I think A change is good I
think I i' like to change stuff up I
always want change how long have you
been here though two years one
year apartment yeah I was in Staten
Island remember we you had another place
that I was in no but downtown I was
somewhere else with Christmas Studio
that was at my podcast Studio which we
still which we still have we we still
are doing that there it until they you
know raise the rent on the lease yeah
and then I'll just imagine I just move
my podcast Studio to Staten Island but
we don't I don't live
there you do it in
Baltimore you just go to some random
City yeah I I do it in Afghanistan
Chattanooga Afghanistan yeah yeah where
is
it would you perform for the troops they
asked you yes I know I feel like we're
going to get asked I feel like we're
going you never did we are pered I think
we are I think we're going to go and
then I think we're going to have to go
we're going to perform for the will you
go to an active war zone to entertain
the troops like what if it's like they
were like dude you need to go like you
got to go would you go yeah like CU that
will happen that that's happened like
the middle of World War II like yes
would you I would go I would feel like I
would feel like because it's so
emasculating for me to be like I would
literally die the second I stepped off a
warship I would die of like like
something would happen I'd get bit by
like a spider and have like have like an
allergic like I feel like I can't yeah
yeah like I I choke on like I choke on
like a a Bo and Berry
yeah it wouldn't be from the war yeah
yeah I would die some other thing a
urinary TR yeah I'd get a UTI and and
slowly die and wither away on the
battlefield like I feel like the only
way I can help serve my country is with
the comedy so I would feel like I would
have to
I would absolutely I do I you know I
never say stuff like this and I know you
know me and you and I are similar this
way I know I joke and I'm miserable I I
really am pretty positive in a lot of
ways I do think we're going to war I
know that's fine it is what it is it is
what it is I really just hope CU we have
daughters like I really just hope like
the war doesn't drag on and then like
one of my daughters gets drafted no
we're not it's not it's not going to go
on long and I don't think it's coming
here I don't I like there's there's
limits to it but I I I do think it's a
nightmare right now yeah well I mean but
then I read about history like I'm
reading this book The People's History
of the United States by Howard zins and
then it's like you realize like even
though things are horrific right now
it's like the the world in the 1600s
that's what I'm up to right now was so
nuts like it was so nuts if you I read
just read this one chapter about how you
know like cuz cuz there's a there's a
thing going around now in history about
like slavery right about how oh well
people will say well black people other
Africans had slaves and Africans sold
the slaves to the Portuguese who then
sold them to the United States so
everybody's involved which is like that
is that fact is true Africans did have
slaves but the American slavery was like
particularly very very very cruel if you
in this [__] late 1600s if you were a
Slave and you stole something or did
something there were reports of like a
slave master in order to strike fear and
the other slaves to not run away they
would take you and slowly roast you over
an open fire for 8 to 10 hours and the
town would come and watch and that's
what they would do just slowly roast you
8 to 10 hours like like a like a dead
like you would do with like a an already
dead pig in like Hawaii that's what they
would do so like that doesn't happen now
you know what I mean that is
unbelievable yeah that's what I was
reading I was reading that on I want to
get that book that sounds really yeah
it's called it's called Uh I think the
people's History of the United States
you have to text that to me okay I'm I
just going to text you that chapter a
people's History of the United States
Howard zins or Zin um but I'm like so
when I read stuff like that I'm like
okay there are horrific things that
happen in the world all the time but
like we've gotten better since then you
know what I mean but it's still bad now
but I wonder like now 300 years from now
you know are they going to be like look
at how horrific and barbaric they were
back
then I I think so right I think so I
mean it's you know but I know what you
mean like it's just it's it's history
and there's war and it it's horrible
there's always been War I know you know
what I think too I've been thinking I
was thinking about this and I said it um
to the person I was sitting next to on
my Jeet Blue flight home and they had no
response I said to them they were
sleeping yes there there was no one
there yes I said to that I how about
this an Indian man was sleeping on my
flight the whole time he slept for like
4 hours and I thought he was meditating
and I was like literally next to him and
I said to him I was like I can't believe
like how Zen you are like it's amazing
like it's like a beautiful thing like
what what book are you reading he was
like I'm an
alcoholic he was like I I took three
Xanax and I'm going through a divorce
with my wife shivna um
shivna but I think that um I think that
this is great stuff for hey babe keep it
in I think that I think that
um I was reading this other book where
it's like humans o says Homo sapiens
right where the we there was many other
forms of humans but like 10 of them but
we are the ones the homo sapiens no
matter what race you are we you are Homo
sapan as far as we know and our sect of
of humanoid was the most violent that's
why we out the genol we are all the most
violent no matter if you're from India
us it doesn't matter Homo sapiens in
general we're the most violent so our
our our factory setting is to be violent
and at War and when we're not at War
when there's peace time then our brains
will make up things to go to war with
like in the really really really really
really Elite classes where like you live
in America you'll make up a war about
your gender or you'll make up a war
about you know that your dad hates you
or something and then in the in the
lower part parts of it like you know
third world countries you're just
actually at physical War but it's one of
those things where it's like a default
setting where I think you can't be at
peace a human brain can't be at peace
because that's not in we'll always find
something to fight and complain about
that's like it's like a it's just what
we were coded with because we were the
ones who were at War it makes complete
sense yeah and then uh yeah and I said
that to the lady sitting next to me and
she just pepper sprayed
me because you were grabbing your ti
while you were telling yeah she was like
do you say tubberware
yeah it's really I mean the thing that's
the thing Tu the thing that's really
like just freaks me out is the division
I mean it's just getting
[Music]
worse percentages yeah uh it's just
getting wor like and it's and it's
getting more and more comp complicated
like it's like like liberals Democrat
it's getting more divided more crazy
more it's just everything is so it is it
is but the thing is that's like the
internet and the no I know no because
because I saw this stat that said it was
about perception versus reality right
and perception was say like take
Republicans and Democrats how far apart
they are on issues immigration safety
child care all that you would think like
the people said okay 90% of Democrats
would vote this way 40% of Republicans
this perception right and then when you
do reality when they actually pulled the
people you found that 98% of Republicans
and Democrats wanted the same thing it
was all the same thing it's just the
perception is that you're so radically
different but the reality is is that
you're actually not different at all
like the basic needs are what just every
person wants and the ba you have a very
very small percentage of like Fringe
people that get crazy about stuff I
agree and they is the on obviously get
the platforms but but so but in reality
you're it's not that like there's
nothing that you want that's different
from somebody who's like you know like
eating Arctic char with their hands in
you know some Eskimo or Inuit sorry some
Inuit pie who who um is you know just
living in Antarctic uh living in the
Arctic Circle they want the same thing
that we want which is just to love our
kids and eventually get a sex
change
that would be funny to do some reality
show of like going to like real like
crazy like you know Inuit tribes or like
tribes in the rainforest and then pay
for it and see who wants the sex change
see if any of them also like see see
what problems they have yeah it would be
yeah you think you could ever do it get
a sex change no no no I I've always felt
male in a lot of ways so I really do
understand the whole gender thing
what were you for
Halloween um I wasn't and I was I was
pretending to be happy that's what I was
for Halloween for half the day with my
kids what were you uh Weird Al Yankovich
that's hilarious did you put up pictures
no I wasn't oh I went as uh the Joker I
just looked like a gay guy that should
have been
hard yeah I I um I was the Joker do you
know during Halloween I my mom used to
we would go trick-or-treating for hours
and hours and hours and there were some
years that my mom would only let us take
have this is really horrible one piece
of
candy I swear to God I know it was bad
she would only let you eat one no wonder
why I got fat disorder I know so I would
take like even if it was like [__] with
the needle sticking out of it I would
take the biggest piece of candy out of
the like it was I find the biggest piece
like you know it was usually like a
Snickers or three musketeers or like a
um whatever whatever it's called I I
can't remember but I would take whatever
was biggest in the thing and then she
would hide it and I for months would go
through all the can she'd forget where
she hid it she was very flighty and I
would eat the
entire bag of candy that I went I would
eat it anyway and she would didn't even
know that I ate it cuz she forgot that
she put it somewhere isn't that
incredible yeah [__] mom's I know the
worst she meant well but it was so crazy
yeah yeah I know I uh I don't uh my mom
would yeah my mom would just let me eat
anything and just like furiously
masturbate all over the house she didn't
care she didn't NOP she didn't give a
[__] at all she would just let me you
ever do it in front of her no no that
would be hot
never I'm trying to think no no but they
only circumcised me when I was 15 really
yeah that
young I yeah I wore uh I got circumcised
and then I um I wore it I wore it like a
pop hat you still have it cuz I'd love
to play with it my for skin yeah see it
I wore them as earrings to the Pink
concert yesterday oh wow did she see
them when she was on stage when she was
flying by she grabbed it I'd love to
wear them as ear plugs on the road cuz I
always wear earplugs
all right great ending yeah I think um I
think about 80 I think 70% of this we
can use then 30% 30% we'll cut out and
we'll play at our
funerals how do you want to be
buried in
[Laughter]
chocolate let me say that again without
the cough how do you want to be buried
in
chocolate love it in demon really what
you think before you before you die do
you want to have sex with one more
biological male I don't want to but I
would never say I wouldn't
okay yeah I'm very confused right
now we all are I mean we all are
confused we all are but you know day by
day that's what I do day by day I'm I'm
uh no I I don't know I'm never like I
never you know the thing is like I was
with guys and girls for a long time and
then I ended up with a woman I haven't
been with a guy since but I really have
never said that I'm 100% a full lesbian
I certainly prefer women right and but I
I the thing with men is I couldn't fall
in love with a guy like I slept with
guys but I didn't want to like hang out
with them the next day not I I'm friends
with so many men but I didn't want to
like be in a relationship with a guy put
it that way right right right but I
wasn't disgusted by having sex with but
if you found like a real girly man no I
was into I was into guys guys got like a
guy not a not like how you doing but
like I wasn't into like a girly guy
right all right yeah well listen
whatever your sexual preface is it's
what it is I mean everyone's on like a
spect you know everybody I know I mean I
don't mean a spectrum like they are like
you were talking about I know I'll
probably get [__] for that but take it
out no I guess she
can what do you guys
think it's a fair point yeah everyone's
really playing the Spectrum
card just getting more popular it is
getting more popular which is it's just
all weird to me it all goes back to
because everyone's at peace so their
brains are wishing for War I also think
it's a Tik Tok thing I think it's just
Tik Tok yeah it is Tik Tok yeah I was we
were I was telling pimp before I'm not
going to let I know like YouTube and the
internet is the way to go I get it but
it's so much like the thing is I know
that like Disney and all these companies
I get how they're like oh they own half
the porn and they're evil and Snow White
sends a bad message the bottom line is
it's made and edited by like
professionals that have been in for a
long time so I'd rather my kids watch
Netflix and Disney than just whatever on
YouTube that some guy from his basement
in Pittsburgh just put up even if it's
wholesome content I just I still do
trust the big networks more than I trust
just open-ended YouTube stuff I don't
even know what you're talking about that
about Netflix and Disney well I'm just
saying like like you'll go on the
Internet or like now people will say
like oh the content on Disney is like
how could you watch that it's like you
know it's racist and it's what whatever
[__] and I'm like but I'm like I
rather just I feel so much safer just
letting my kids scroll through Disney
plus than than even in the kids YouTube
channels cuz I'm like I don't know oh I
agree with you completely like some
parent putting your 8-year-old kid on
YouTube to get views all Steed in the
wrong thing I agree with you completely
and they're just monetizing their own
children and then that's what my
daughter wants and I'm like no like you
and her attitude
sometimes I deal the I we have the exact
same problem it's exact I'm like what
were you just watching that made you
like so snotty yeah totally it's these
kids because they're these kids are
snotty because they're making a lot of
money but their parents are like forcing
them to do it but I will say there was a
lot of kids who got snotty from Disney
Channel like Hannah Montana I think's
always a degree of well I think the
difference is though what I think the
difference is is because they're seeing
it on TV or like in a movie a child's
brain says well they're like an actor or
like yes they still will get S I agree
but but there's still like that wall up
there's still a little where with
YouTube they think oh that kid is just
like me like I could be on YouTube too
they're they're seeing so then they
start to act they feel more entitled to
act that way cuz they're like oh that
person's acting like that way that's
another 8-year-old girl that's you know
you sometimes fil me you know on when I
do silly things so they think they could
do it yeah so they should really go
after the parents that's like an
indentured servant it is it is yeah
you're right indentured servitude that's
what it is that's also in the people's
History of the United States the poor
whites the poor whites were the big
indentured servants in the colonial
America
MH look at how wide Jessica can open her
mouth I was good at that look at that
she wants to I was yeah that was it was
good mhm I want to go eat a dark
chocolate covered gingerbread cookie I
never heard of that before they have him
at the bakery on the corner that sounds
amazing yeah I went into the bakery this
morning and I got coffee and I just
looked at all the sweets and I and I and
I just left but now I'm going to go back
and eat one that sounds good though I
love dark chocolate and I love
gingerbread cookies so where can people
see you at the
bakery go to is it j jessica.com k i RS
o n and the big thing is is that I have
a crowd work special coming out which to
be honest I've heard about this crowd
work special from multiple sources being
like that you killed like they've never
seen it like TR um you know we always
when someone comes on we talk about
their special you know we want to give
them credit and all that comedy's very
hard but I I'm being genuinely serious
folks I've heard from like literally
like five different people like you have
to see oh hard Jessica killed on the
special so go watch it because I'm be
honest I haven't seen it and I get
excited when I think about it cuz I'm
like I'm going to go watch it because
all I've heard is how nuts it was you're
getting a copy of it beforehand but it's
on
youtube.com jesica kersen comedy and
it's I'm really directed by the homeless
pimp yes pimp directed it it's so he's
amazing yes yes and he did all the
editing the clips I mean you're so
unreal thank you so are you it was a
nuts nuts it was nuts it really wasend
in a song that is insane yeah I I had a
live band at the comedy Celler
underground and I improved songs I've
never done that in my entire career I
sang on stage my God and improved songs
the audience could not have been better
it was sick and it's called No material
I did not do one joke it's all improv
crowd work and I mean I never say this
but I think it's the funniest thing I've
ever done in my career like and you just
felt amazing like it was one of those
things where like if you hadn't captured
that on camera you'd be like that was
one of the best nights of my like it
actually deserved to be a special cuz it
was truly special for you it was it was
it was Unreal like it was I love to see
that it couldn't have been better than
it was all right well go watch it you
know uh where it is we just told you
youtube.com/ JY kerson heard it was the
best Jessica kerson comedy Jessica
kerson comedy y um one of the best
specials directed by Hometown favorite
one of us homeless pimp so go all the
hey babes taste Buddies go do it and uh
I love you I love you honey love you so
much I'll see you at the
[Laughter]
War uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe